the las vegas market underway for its
five-day run attracting tens of
thousands of vendors displaying their
best in furniture home decor and gifts
it's so busy out there but the
challenges that the industry face are
even bigger and buyers say they just
can't seem to catch a break
it's just beyond ridiculous it's a harsh
reality for leslie hadley and deanna
anderson who are trying to keep their
design business open during the pandemic
the people are still spending money
people still need designers
so they're not to be able to get this
the goods at a timely manner is really
frustrating the utah business owners are
just one of tens of thousands attending
this year's bi-annual las vegas market
in downtown hoping to get more clients
despite a lower attendance turnout
according to event officials the buyers
that are here we think it's about 60
percent of pre-pandemic
they're buying the they're virtually
they need inventory consumer demand is
at the highest level has probably been
for furnishings and the housing market
is robust ceo and chairman of
international market centers robert
meresich tells us attendees are looking
for the latest trends and available
product customers are placing more
orders he says and it's not slowing down
this year there's going to be a
continuation there there will continue
to be
cost increases because of wage inflation
probably the cost for ocean freight has
has topped out we've all been affected
by it we've tried our best
to to get everything
going as smoothly as possible but
there's challenges curt schroeder with
hobo says their products are made in
china but handling the triggy demand
well something most agree on the one
good thing is that they all understand
that that's the situation you know it is
what it is
well mayor stitch says americans have
been able to collect some cash with
things like the stimulus checks and wage
inflation american consumers he says
like to spend and that is exactly what
we're seeing